next we have another story from idaho
i'm proud to say my home state is known
for its delicious delicious potatoes
and now you can actually sleep in a
giant potato druid
yeah it's called the big idaho potato
hotel it can fit two people as a comfy
bed and a fireplace so you can make it
nice and toasty and there's even a
soaking tub in there ross andrew would
you come visit i don't stay in that
potato uh uh
sleep in a potato uh you you know where
you sleep in a potato in the master
bedroom
that's so
good
i don't know i would totally go drew
it's so cute and um i definitely have
gone to sleep with a ton of potatoes
inside of me so why not sleep inside of
a potato you also went to
look at some potatoes recently too look
at this what i went to a potato cellar
and it's crazy because there were a
thousand potatoes and in that picture i
see i'm on top of potatoes and that's a
stack of a million potatoes and that's
so high up when i look down like
oh my goodness oh my gravy i'm like
gravy by the way
oh my gosh well i mean finally i don't
know about you ross and emmy but talking
about that six ton potato made me hungry
so it's time to perfectly transition
into food news
okay today we're trying a new healthy
salad i say healthy because i don't
think it's that oh right it's like the
most unhealthy stuff i eat
cheese puffs like
every day all right well this is like a
huge recipe from tiktok it's the hot
cheese puff salad and now credit where
credit is due this was created by a user
named ruth it's cilantro cucumber lemon
juice uh tapatio or tapatio
potato potato
yeah but people pronounce it different
ways and of course there's hot cheese
puffs now emmy we know you're not into
the spicy stuff yet i do not like spicy
stuff we're going to have the non-spicy
for you and ross and i are going to try
the spicy no i'll like ranch in it and
then with normal cheese puffs yeah i
didn't get ranch dressing well i think
that's the real that's a different
recipe a less spicy one so ours has hot
cheese puffs in it and and this is not a
salad you're lying to me drew barrymore
but i'm gonna
let's just like three two one let's all
right three two one here we go
okay i gotta say that's actually kinda
good i i'm just eating i'm not eating
the cheese puffs thank you very much uh
but it is seasoning all the cucumber and
i'm here for it mm-hmm i actually like
this
probably really good like legit really
good yeah no this is like how george
your emmy is it good
i mean it's a little office but a little
off but good
little off i thought it would be gross
what's off about it
like
the ranches
we had with these puffs
i have to say this one's very refreshing
it surprises me uh-huh and because i
think ours is a little bougie you got
fresh cilantro i don't know that they're
doing that on tick-tock land but this is
a it's actually delicious i'm very
surprised
[Music]